child Gladiators the queen trading her
feet for information another creepy
prophecy fulfilled the second to last
episode of House of the Dragon was as
shocking as ever here's what you might
have missed
one of the ways in which rhaenyra and
the blacks underestimated their foes the
greens was by vacating so many small
Council seats to the high towers and
their allies
Otto Hightower returned to a place that
murdered Lionel strong as hand Thailand
Lannister no friend of rhaenyra's took
over for Lord Corless as master of ships
and Jasper Wilde was installed as master
of laws maester Orwell was promoted
after Grand maester Melos died and
Christine Cole has been loyal to Alison
ever since rhaenyra declined his
marriage proposal that left only master
of coin Lyman beesbury to defend
rhaenyra's claim as he mentions in his
exasperated speech he's the council's
longest serving member at age 76. his
age has made a joke of in previous
episodes when he fails to keep up with
the pace of the conversation and boss a
group with his detailed accounting
however in episode 9 it's clear he's
been left out of the loop for a more
explicit purpose the rest of the council
has been planning to install aegon
regardless of Alison's misinterpret
station of her husband's dying words
House of the Dragon likes to foreshadow
plot points with fashion choices as does
Fire and Blood In this case beesberry is
the only person in attendance wearing
red and black Targaryen colors and more
specifically rhaenyra's colors when he
refuses to back down so Kristen crushes
his face against his ceremonial small
Council ball the first casualty in the
post for saris Civil War era a new Queen
Elena is the easiest member of the
greens to root for unfortunately rooting
for her rarely does any good sweet
eccentric Helena appears to be cursed
she can see what's coming but she has no
way of preventing it you will Dragon one
day he'll have to close an eye so far
her prophecies have been communicated in
seemingly random hushed phrases but in
the green Council we see her
embroidering a spider while spending
time with her young children Helena
famously loves bugs but there's more to
her cross stitching than meets the eye
one of the little spiders is your lady
in waiting larys learns that Otto has
been using a web of spies to glean
sensitive information in exchange for
letting him look at her feet he tells
the queen that's her handmaiden Talia is
one of them but Alison to have the upper
hand that whisper Network must be
silenced there is one way to destroy his
advantage
it must be taken out
the head Elena also repeats the phrase
she said last episode of the dinner only
this time she says it with much more
anger and urgency
[Music]
the episode ends of course with that
Beast breaking through the boars with
Princess rhaenice on his back
in an episode 8 exchange that was almost
too quick and too quiet for audiences to
catch Queen Alison mistook one Cargill
twin for the other you're great a Mata
has arisen that requires your attention
whatever it is sir I reckon you need to
wait America Grace
and Fire and Blood thus the point of the
maddeningly named Sir Eric with an A and
Sir Eric with an E they're said to be so
precisely identical that even the other
members of the kingsguard can't tell
them apart like Alison's viewers may
have struggled to keep track of which
twin was which so Eric with an e is
Prince aegon swarm protector and is thus
exposed to his debauchery in the
fighting pets Eric with an E hopes that
his brother will finally understand who
aegon really is and how unsuited he is
for leadership this makes Eric with an E
most empathetic to a nearest claim which
we see when he attempts to rescue
princess rhaenis with me princess
I cannot let this treachery stand But
Eric with an E loses her in the crowds
forcibly assembling the dragon pit for
aegon's coronation thankfully rhaenys is
more than capable of taking care of
herself while we don't know what's
happened to Eric with an a after losing
his sword fight to Kristen we can be
sure that this isn't the last we've seen
of the Cargill twins who now seemingly
find themselves on opposite sides of a
civil war
Lord Caswell was a gentleman who
attended rhaenira on the stairs after
the birth of her third son if I may be
of any service
and conspicuously Caswell was the only
person who came out to greet the
princess and her party when they arrived
at King's Landing in episode 8. after
the greens conspired to usurp the Iron
Throne Otto gathers the Snowballs in the
throne room and asked them to bend the
knee under the guise of Freedom many do
reading the writing on the wall but the
lady of house fell from Storm's end does
not and another Lord says he'll have to
consult with his people before declining
to back aegon as king we could assume
that both are carried off to the
dungeons the audience knows Lord Caswell
to be loyal to Rayner but he wavers and
bends the knee after all seemingly to
save his own skin not so Caswell
attempts to flee shortly after but is
caught he insists he's no friend of
rhaenyra's however observant hilarious
has kept his eye on the Lord of
bitterbridge and knows he's exceedingly
fond of the Princess
Otto orders the king's Justice and that
night Rey Nissan Eric with an E passed
by his hanging lifeless body as they try
their own daring escape from the red
keep
as soon as the greens out maneuver the
blacks the high Towers turn on each
other Alison and Otto both position
themselves to become the true ruler of a
source of unofficial regions to aegon
who is not interested in ruling when sir
Kristen and amons to feed the twins for
possession of aegon Alison declares
herself the winner and begins arranging
the ceremony during which he'll be
anointed the next Sovereign she tells
also that he'll be sworn in with his
namesake aegon's crown and sword the
namesake to whom she's referring is
obviously aegon the Conqueror as her son
will become king aegon the second as
it's depicted in House of the Dragon
aegon wore a less ornate crown of
Valyrian steel encrusted with large
rubies he also wielded blackfyre The
ancestral Valyrian steel Blade the other
ancestral Targaryen sword as Damon's
weapon Dark sister Alison's hopes these
totems will inspire renewed reverence
for Targaryen rule among the people
however we know from the book that
aegon's Crown was also worn by his son
maegor the cruel who also he came to
possess both dark sister and blackfyre
when aegon iI is crowned and thrusts The
Sword in the air he's more the image of
maegor than aegon and Alison seems to
fear she may have made a mistake she
made a second mistake in getting the
conqueror's crown out of storage the one
worn by Jay Harris and viserys is up for
grabs now and now there's a scorned
princess in the market for one with
plenty of people still loyal to her in
King's Landing
[Music]